y vamos ahora con los titulares de la
prensa internacional como ya es
costumbre con rosa pérez más de euros a
muy buen día bienvenida vamos a empezar
hablando de la reina isabel segunda
comenzamos con the times que titula la
reina está de buen ánimo tras pasar la
noche en el hospital este es un artículo
que hizo el periodista valentín loud
buenos días raúl exactamente nos hemos
fijado en la prensa británica pero
evidente mediante medios de alrededor
del mundo se han hecho eco de esta
noticia pues porque la reina isabel esa
reina recordemos del reino unido- y la
commonwealth pero es pues una monarca
influyente alrededor del planeta y
empezamos exacto con the times que pues
se cita el comunicado de la propia casa
real diciendo siguiendo el consejo
médico de descansar unos días la reina
fue al hospital el miércoles por la
tarde para someterse a pruebas
preliminares regresó al castillo de
windsor a la hora del almuerzo del
jueves y sigue de buen ánimo y
simplemente queríamos aclarar en
relación al titular de este artículo que
el buckingham palace es la residencia
oficial de la reina en la capital del
reino unido- en londres pero que el
castillo de windsor es una especie de
segunda residencia donde la reina
acostumbra a pasar pues por ejemplo sus
fines de semana y dónde va a descansar
estos días vamos ahora con llegar ya
narros a la reina pasó la noche en el
hospital tras cancelar su visita a
irlanda del norte este artículos deja
retailer exacto y the gardian destaca
que esta es su primera noche en el
hospital desde 2013 por otro lado pues
tal y como nos comentaba luisa nuestra
corresponsal en reino unido- que es la
casa real y ha informado que la reina ha
empezado a desempeñar tareas ligeras y
el periódico también señala que se ha
mantenido muy ocupada desde el
fallecimiento de su esposo el duque de
edimburgo y precisamente este este medio
de gharyan enlaza con una noticia
también de principios de semana cuando
la reina rechazó la condecoración el
premio de persona del año precisamente
esto una condecoración que se otorga a
las personas mayores pues en relación a
sus logros y el representante de la
reina que pues se envió una carta a la
organización
cuando el rechazo de la monarca este
premio dijo en la carta su majestad cree
que uno es tan mayor como se siente pero
recordemos que en términos biológicos la
reina tiene 95 años y que el próximo 6
de febrero de 2022 va a cumplir 75 años
en el trono dios mío vamos ahora con the
song alivio real alivio que todavía la
reina esté viva y de buen ánimo el
artículo es de britta showman y maxwell
que son exacto y de sant lo destacable
es que en pocas horas ha cambiado el
titular de shock real a este alivio que
comentábamos y es que precisamente fue
el de sant quien forzó en cierto modo el
comunicado del buckingham palace porque
fue este medio más a tabloide quien pues
filtró esta visita de la reina al
hospital y también señala que fueron los
doctores reales quien
aconsejaron a la reina que visitara el
hospital por términos por temas de
precaución y también pues tal y como nos
comentaba luisa que se espera la
presencia de la reina en la cob 26 este
1 noviembre en glasgow así es y también
vamos a tener una cápsula especial con
nuestra enviada especial marina colorado
a glasgow hasta con 26 vamos a cambiar
ahora tema rosa vamos con the time como
la era a pandémica disuadió a los
testigos de intentar detener una
violación dios esto el artículo lo hizo
melisa chang mira este articulo raúl
hacer referencia a un suceso que tuvo
lugar la noche del 13 de octubre en un
tren de filadelfia cuando un hombre de
35 años violó a una mujer ante la
inacción de los presentes en este tren
suburbano de filadelfia no fue hasta que
un trabajador pues vio la escena y avisó
al resto del personal del tren que
llamaron a la policía y pues detuvieron
la agresión entonces pues este artículo
recoge tanto la voz de las autoridades
como de distintos psicólogos que
atribuyen los hechos principalmente a
dos cuestiones por un lado dicen esto no
es algo nuevo de hecho los psicólogos
estudian desde hace tiempo el llamado
efecto espectador que básicamente
consiste en que como más testigos hay en
una situación así
y sentimos a nivel individual la
responsabilidad la responsabilidad y la
necesidad de actuar no porque nos
dejamos guiar por la lógica de otra
persona pues ya lo hará pero por otro
lado señalan que la pandemia ha
acentuado todavía más este temor
respecto a los desconocidos este
aislamiento y que precisan
individualismo este individualismo no
que si bien no es nuevo pues se ha visto
acentuado al pues acerca después de
todas estas restricciones sanitarias y
etcétera y precisamente lo que señalan
los psicólogos es que cuando una persona
interviene pues en este tipo de casos
cuando la primera persona interviene la
segunda se suma mucho más rápido y que
es la fuerza del colectivo lo que puede
frenar este tipo hago con el artículo
rosa de la replay del filadelfia citizen
símbolo de la época rápidamente ya para
pasar el invitado el día exacto pues
este este medio este análisis lo que
recoge es precisamente esta pérdida de
la fuerza del colectivo y señala que si
bien se equivocaban los que decían que
tras la pandemia las ciudades iban a
morir pues no es verdad estamos viendo
como retoman a mucha actividad atrás el
levantamiento de las restricciones
sanitarias pero este artículo se plantea
y si lo que estamos perdiendo realmente
es este sentimiento de ciudadanía y de
pertenencia al colectivo como ha
cambiado el mundo rosa después de la
pandemia de kobe 19 hasta en nuestra
mente también eso va a ser un tema
pronto de nuestro programa directo
américa rosa gracias nos vemos el lunes
con más revista de prensa nosotros
pasamos a nuestro primer invitado al día
[Música]